[Music]
in dice functional family news nice
functional dice function that's our
family at least their dice are
functioning no my family loves me
you guys are a family hello really not I
don't beat my dogs
what I never know I think I know I think
I know where he's going
we're dysfunctional family I don't beat
my dogs it makes you sad bro
yeah that's in case you didn't hear me
maybe one more time let me take a crack
at it let me please please please decode
it yeah so when you picture a family you
picture a family unit right mom dad kids
so in your brain our dogs are the kids
and you're a thousand percent and you're
thinking that a dysfunctional family
would beat their children but you would
not be your children which are our dogs
so you don't beat your dogs so there you
just shall just sit in for Bart cuz
Bart's like okay what Josie right now
you think always a need to codes it so
you just why is that so hard to
understand we beat the dog at least to
me I was like what that was the point I
don't beat my dog it's like you said
something crazy but you looked at us
like we were stupid right I brush my
teeth with rocks we go what and you go
anything I brush my teeth with rocks
well you didn't you didn't fall into my
trap traps was to make it sound like she
beats the dog so many layers were
involved and then Bart's like okay what
Joe's saying I understand exactly what
he's saying he's like he's saying that
he brushes his teeth with rocks so
because he wants his teeth to be really
clean and then Joe's like even more good
news because the explanation is just as
tough as the it's just a longer way of
saying the same dumb [ __ ]
an entire company out of it yeah it's
the best bet I respect something in boy
gonna buy who I can trust emitter by
abhishek Aravalli oh you do I know that
name I will shake this way well not a
guy is that Spanish Abhishek is Indian
shout out to Abhishek this is my pair of
store keys Habash I'll be checking that
out to see if there's really
[Applause]
yeah good one I'm sorry [ __ ] 30 years
knowing they can I never thought of that
joke what the [ __ ] were you yeah
macalmon right now again the white side
of funds is what I love right it is like
I haven't talked to you in 20 years what
the [ __ ] you like I've heard that every
day of my father was ran over by a lawn
mower after attacking his son with the
change my god Florida I think it's white
people because they actually cut their
own lawn
okay wait Laura he's cutting the lawn
really why people would they don't be
hire us Mexican this was rich Lampe
great white people love to drink beer in
Ohio mother Lorna neither who who
actually has one of those lawn mower
that you sit on like a tractor Oh true
white people yep poor white people and
mow their own lawns it's part of the
dream like is having a beer in your hand
while you're on a John Deere and you're
mowing your lawn that's like the dream
and we live in LA where there's not much
lon
like in other places there's a lotta lon
and they're pretty affordable I'm not
like crazy expensive you can finance one
alright so this takes place in Tennessee
Tennessee and a chainsaw I don't know
any other people but construction
workers and stuffed I got a chainsaw but
they did answer the age-old question who
would win a lot more or chainsaw this
sounds like a final destination killed
in on Jesus his father who's 76 years
old
his name is Douglas this is what he
looks like
Douglas Wow no don't you do bit to that
face and I look like [ __ ] desert or
something that by the way his face
should be on the Tennessee flag dude
that is a Tennessee man Tennessee I
think equals Tennessee I could picture
his face on a jar of jam Douglass Jam
yes so Douglass do bless what he was
attacking his son with an active
chainsaw who know his son was mowing the
lawn at that time and so what he ended
up doing in order to defend himself is
logically you know you run over your dad
with the whole room well if he's coming
out with a active chainsaw so
potentially choice that's still really
scary combo a long reach and a lawnmower
you know I mean you may be he's leaning
back
well you still can't drive away from him
he can't chase you he's a [ __ ] geezer
I feel you can just throw the [ __ ]
chainsaw and you'd be [ __ ] that's true
but I'll just land like right there is
heavy but imagine throwing a chainsaw
you can get yourself with it if it's
that you yeah you know what sir this
dude before that so Douglas ended up
losing his leg what Douglas is the dead
dad that was attacking with the chainsaw
huh
why was he attacking with a chainsaw
yeah they don't really say they just say
that they had an ongoing dispute and a
history of problems with him and others
in the family some dispute how young how
old is his son they don't tell me I'm
sick he's like seven yeah the son's got
to be like 50 yeah why are you still
fighting with your [ __ ] dad like that
dude yo my mom still fights with my
grandma's hilarious the groom has
Alzheimer just run away he this guy's 70
years old
you can't [ __ ] outrun anything yeah
butterfly but if you have to get off
take the time to get off the lawn mower
he's gonna come around and get you oh
well you're on a riding lawnmower you
can't outrun him on that thing I think
those six miles an hour I don't know if
he was writing it or he was it was
pushing it oh I just pictured one of
those like riding so did I I pictured
that to take off someone's leg like I
don't feel like a normal small push
mower can actually take someone's life
yeah he basically run his ass over but
maybe it could huh it could be like
those old ones where there's actual
blades yeah yeah you remember those so
stupid of the old guy because it's like
did you and 70 some odd years just
perfectly fine undamaged and the one
little thing that the last few years of
you're like yeah but he puts a good time
to lose a leg look yeah that's the best
time is when you don't need it
he's taking more risk now he's like you
know have you guys ever used a non
mortar [ __ ] would you call it non
motor Nam ordered glass-cutter thing
ever
I've seen him know there's this old
school right so like my friend's grandpa
had one and I had this like fascination
with cutting grass and then he let me
use it and it was [ __ ] dope so it
uses no like electricity or [ __ ] more
or anything is just it spins like this
doesn't it look like them it looks like
the paint roller brush before you put
everything on yeah I better
the more you push it the faster it goes
and it just so fascinated I was like
[ __ ] yeah this is dope that reminds me
of those [ __ ] tricked you to do
chores
cutting grass I'm like what I started a
lot more busy things get good it's kind
of fun though like what things get yeah
oh that's true I got a we call it the
weed whacker and I made a design in his
backyard and I [ __ ] up the grass so
hard we did good but I couldn't hold it
down but my friend tech took it over so
you sold it
I'm sorry no I just let him keep the
route do's gave away your business oh no
I was just gonna say that reminds me of
those little um like non-motor things
and the little sweeper things that they
use in the restaurant
oh the vacuum oh this buffer thing well
they just like move it and it like picks
up the little crumbs and stuff I used to
love those when I was a kid like every
time they would they would use it I
would be watching this like an actual it
looks like this I worked in a restaurant
for a long time but I can't remember
what it's called there's two anything it
has a little like pan thing at the top
that pops open yeah I used to be
obsessed with those so I understand your
obsession do Roombas work I guess I
bought one for my uncle are expensive 50
don't work they work a decent amount so
like I had one of them returned it
because it's not gonna be as clean as
you doing it yourself right so if you're
not very obsessive over it and you want
to just be decently clean in between
yeah yeah it's like good maintenance
when they figure that shit's gonna be so
sick yeah I heard that they have one
that mops
and sweeps or the rich people houses
where they have the vacuum cleaner vents
on the bottom and you just sweep it into
there oh yeah so tight yeah anyway so
this father here he faces one count of
attempted second-degree murder
and a probation violation because he was
previously convicted for aggravated
assault imagine being that old and still
angry oh I know his angry old people
I'll be just as angry when I'm all [ __ ]
yeah absolutely I can't wait to be an
old angry man
little argument when I was the argument
a little conversation with Muriel
because there was just uh older Asian
men in Hawaii that was [ __ ] hella rude
to us in a Walmart and I was like and
she was like oh it's okay he's all
that's like the fact that he was a
[ __ ] dick you doesn't mean if he's a
dick now he was worse when he was
younger dude true when they had energy
they're probably beating people yeah or
some [ __ ] I was like that guy was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I think they're
just grumpy cuz they don't feel good
yeah but so you don't
[Music]